[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
le fn accusé de plagiat marine le pen a
repris hier des passages d'un discours
sur l'identité prononcé il ya peu par
françois fillon
un clin d'oeil selon l'entourage de la
candidate frontiste qui assume la droite
a dénoncé une grossière tentative
d'acheter les électeurs
le décryptage à suivre à cinq jours du
second tour emmanuel macron reste favori
dans les sondages malgré un resserrement
des écarts et l'absence de front
républicain comme en 2002 le niveau
d'abstention et le nombre de votes
blancs seront aussi scrutés à la loupe
car il pourrait affaiblir le président
sortant la consigne de vote de nouveau
en débat chez les républicains le parti
reste très divisé sur cette question qui
pourrait ressurgir ce soir lors du
bureau politique qui seront d'ailleurs
en direct avec sa verrière ogec dans un
instant et pour réagir à cette émission
présidentielle 360
le hashtag sur twitter mais avant de
développer tous ses titres les résultats
de la consultation de la france
insoumise
les 430 mille personnes qui ont apporté
leur soutien à jean-luc mélenchon devait
se prononcer sur la conduite à tenir au
second tour et ils ont opté en deux
tiers pour le vote blanc ou l'abstention
amflora sauvage voter blanc voter
emmanuel macron s'abstenir c'était le
choix proposé aux quelque 430 mille
personnes qui ont apporté leur soutien à
jean-luc mélenchon sur sa plateforme
internet et ils ont tranché ce sera le
vote blanc pour 36% des personnes
interrogées 34 % choisissent emmanuel
macron et 29% l'abstention s'est traduit
la vie de françois soumises en tout cas
bien mieux que des sondages donc voilà
ça sert à ça et je pense que c'est une
façon aussi de respecter justement la
décision de tous ceux qui sont dans
france insoumise
c'est peut-être une forme nouvelle il
faut s'y habituer sais c'est pas
entre guillemets le sommet où nous qui
envoient des consignes c'est tous ceux
qui appartiennent à ce mouvement qui
donnent leur avis un avis qui reste
consultatif
jean luc mélenchon le porte-voix de la
france insoumise avait simplement dit
qu'il fallait faire barrage au front
national il a depuis demandé un geste à
emmanuel macron en faveur de ses
électeurs mais le candidat dans marché a
déposé une fin de non recevoir
de son côté françois fillon a appelé ses
électeurs en bon sens après avoir
déclaré qu'il voterait de macron soir du
premier tour
l ancien candidat ait l'air à la
présidentielle réunissait une centaine
de parlementaires ce matin la maison de
la chimie pour leur délivrer un dernier
message avant de prendre du recul
une façon aussi de les remercier pour
leur soutien écoutez ces réactions
recueillies à la sortie de son pot
d'adieu
il nous a dit de rester unis et il nous
a dit de nous battre et je crois qu'il a
raison c'est par pot de remerciement
bah c'est effectivement un pot de
remerciement ses impôts dehors au revoir
mais c'est aussi un message très très
positif sur la nécessité d'avoir une
droite qui est une droite qui défend ses
valeurs qui défend ses convictions qui
défend ses idées
une droite qui n'est pas la gauche et
une droite qui est étanche avec le fn
lille sera pas la bataille il a été très
clair à ce sujet il a répété tout
simplement ce qu'il avait déjà dit à
deux reprises
le soir du dimanche où il a été battu
quelques jours après également donc il
se tient en retrait mais il souhaite
notre succès ville avant aux élections
législatives et souhaite qu'on continue
de porter les idées que lui-même n'a pas
pu développer comme il voulait souhaité
le développer pendant la campagne des
présidentielles fille qu'un message à la
fois de remerciements et de mobilisation
pour les élections législatives enfin
mobilisation pour nous c'est un message
amical tout simplement vous savez
c'était un moment amical
je crois vous avez fait vous cherchez
sens bien motivés là il ya cinq caméras
et tous vous attendez un grand message
politique un truc mais j'ai peur qu'on
soit tous un peu décevant mais garde un
moment amical après une campagne qui a
été dur passer un moment ensemble un peu
sympathique pot là c'est comme danser ni
plus ni moins et comme on est resté nu
mais ça semble pas gagné pour l'instant
seuls aveux l'unité s'est jamais gagner
sinon ce serait trop facile
et justement on va tout de suite
retrouvé saveria roseq depuis eh bien le
siège des républicains en rue de
vaugirard à paris savait rien un bureau
politique a lieu en ce moment et cette
question du vote macro on pourrait
ressurgir au cours des débats
absolument delphine deux questions au
menu de ce bureau politique des
républicains est tout d'abord et bien
cet appel de la sénatrice fabienne
keller un appel à un vote du bureau
politique un vote explicite au soutien à
emmanuel macron le populisme peut gagner
dimanche vient nous déclaré la sénatrice
je vous propose d'ailleurs de l'écouter
je vais demander au bureau politique de
prendre position clairement et pas par
des périphrases leur est grave pour la
france pour tous les français et pour
l'europe aussi
la dernière fois nous ne sommes pas
passés au vote
je les regretter c'est important qu'à
cette heure tout à fait décisif pour la
france notre mouvement soit capable de
prendre une décision claire je propose
que nous soutenions très clairement
emmanuel macron
voilà alors cette clarification elle est
souhaitée par beaucoup ici au siège des
républicains même position pour la
sénatrice caroline cayeux caroline
cayeux qui était la mi journée à la
maison de la chimie avec françois fillon
là où françois fillon a réuni ses
partisans je vous propose également
d'écouter caroline cayeux toute façon
personne ne soutient madame le pen enfin
soyez ces votes blancs si votre patron
c'est pas écrit nulle part on a dit tout
faire contre l'extrême droite pour moi
on fait tous contre l'extrême droite
on vote macron voilà et l'autre question
au menu de ce bureau politique c'est qui
pour mener la bataille des législatives
car si la droite est bien a perdu la
présidentielle
ici on estime qu'elle peut encore gagner
les législatives et donc imposer une
cohabitation au futur chef de l'état et
là encore eh bien la réponse n'est pas
évidente entre les partisans de françois
baroin et ce et bien qu'ils estiment
qu'une campagne peut se mener son leader
merci beaucoup savaient rien y at il un
début de cacophonie au fn sur la sortie
de l'euro la candidate frontiste
conscient de l'impopularité de cette
mesure change de ton et relègue au
second plan cette disposition qui devait
pourtant conditionné 70% de son
programme économique quentin calmer et
olivier crise et c'est un pilier du
programme économique de marine le pen
et pourtant depuis ce week-end difficile
de comprendre la position de la
candidate sur la sortie de l'euro
samedi dernier marine le pen entérine
une alliance avec nicolas dupont aignan
le texte évoque un calendrier adapté aux
priorités et défis immédiats que le
gouvernement de la france devra relever
un moyen de rassurer les électeurs de
droite sur ce volet du programme
économique
interrogé sur ce point fort ayant fini
pour récuse toute contradiction
le projet l'éclair six mois de
négociations et à partir de quand un
homme l'a tout dès son élection ce que
précise d'accord et nicolas dupont
aignan et c'est très bien c'est que
pendant ces six mois on peut quand même
faire des choses en matière économique
négocier avec les partenaires européens
c'est donc désormais la priorité du
front national bernard mono est un des
artisans de cette partie du programme
selon lui deux
puis ce week end il s'agit de préciser
le programme n'y a pas d'urgence à
sortir de l'euro on est unique de
manière brutale ce qu'il faut c'est
encore une fois qu'il ya un consensus
qui est une renégociation et que ça se
fasse dans l'intérêt général de tous
pour cet autre économiste les
atermoiements du front national sur la
sortie de l'euro sont très
compréhensible je pense qu'aujourd'hui
dans l'opinion publique
certes l'europe n'est pas vu comme un
eldorado où comme quelque chose qui nous
a fait du bien sur le long terme mais on
y tient encore et donc sortir de la zone
euro fait encore plus peur et n'est pas
souhaitée par les français donc si vous
aspirez à être président de la
république aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez
pas faire comme préalable à toute
politique économique
la sortie de la zone euro cette question
essentielle s'annonce déjà comme un
moment fort du débat de demain entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron les
deux candidats que tout oppose sur cette
question et on continue l'analyse de
cette campagne de l'entre-deux tours
avec mes invités sur ce plateau notre
chroniqueuse tam tran huy bonsoir hattab
également avec nous ce soir emmanuel
rivière bonsoir vous êtes directeur
général de kantar public france alors
dans un premier temps entame on va
s'intéresser sur ce qui a fait la une de
l'actualité aujourd'hui cette histoire
de plagiat de marine le pen elle a
repris hier lors de son meeting à
villepinte des phrases entières d'un et
secours de françois fillon on va en
parler mais d'abord on les écoute
maritime brosser la mer du nord qui nous
relie au monde rien sur le monde anglo
saxon lire morgana septentrionale façade
médias mais voyez des civils ont vieilli
les pires histoires et pyrénées paris
qui engage la france qui engage la
france dans cet immense en semaine que
le monde hispanique la frontière usa
l'italie notre salle
tallinn en europe centrale et au delà
l'europe qui oriente pas ces plagiats
tam a vite été repérée sur les réseaux
sociaux où il faut dire que le discours
de françois fillon n'est pas bien vu il
a été prononcé il ya quinze jours au puy
en velay
et à l'heure où les facs shakerz et
autres décodeurs sont les gens il a donc
était très vite repéré quasiment
immédiatement sur les réseaux sociaux
je précise que le premier compte twitter
à avoir donné l alerte c'est ridicule tv
un conte qui a été créée très récemment
au mois de février 2017 qui est
ouvertement pro fillon et qui a très
vite dénoncé un pelage à mot pour mot je
le cite une imposture ce n'est pas ce
que disent pourtant les lieutenants
marine le pen et oui tout autre son de
cloche du côté des proches de marine le
pen on a eu ce matin david rachline son
directeur de campagne qui a parlé je le
cite d'un petit un clin d'oeil une
expression reprise également par florian
philippot un petit clin d'oeil à un
appel du pied à l'électorat de françois
fillon
hors de question d'admettre une erreur
le plagiat serait en tout cas selon eux
calculer ce qui est clair c'est qu'il
est assumée
d'autant que ces phrases sont à
emprunter à l'essayiste paul marie
coûteaux c'est un fort vent partisans de
l'union des droites
oui pas le marais couteau c'est un homme
qui a consacré toute sa vie politique à
l'idée de voir ça y est la droite
républicaine et l'extrême droite
l'ancien député européen a été un temps
président du ciel un parti souverainiste
satellite du front national et qui
appartenait à qui appartient toujours
d'ailleurs au rassemblement bleu marine
il a fait ses classes auprès de philippe
séguin de charles pasqua et il était
aussi l'une des éminences grises de
françois fillon lors de sa campagne et
d'ailleurs et bien ce matin il s'est
réjoui sur twitter il écrit il est
prometteur est significatif que marine
le pen et françois fillon s'exprimant
sur la vocation universelle de la france
le fasse dans les mêmes termes hashtag
d'ailleurs clin d'oeil
l'élément de langage qui a été repris en
choeur par les lieutenants de marine le
pen ces termes d'inspiration gaulliste
sont ceux de mon ouvrage l'europe vers
la guerre nécessaire union des droites
ouais vous l'avez joint d'ailleurs ce
matin par téléphone il va raconter la
genèse de cet emprunt oui ces phrases
sont des éléments de discours que paul
marie coûteaux avait transmis à françois
fillon en vue de son discours du puy en
velay et ce sont donc ces éléments qui
ont été repris par les équipes de marine
le pen
ces phrases elle synthétise des passages
d'un livre qu'il a donc publié en 1997
l'europe vers la guerre des traces
d'ailleurs déjà utilisé nous at il dit
par philippe séguin dont il a été la
plus à la fin des années 90 l'idée pour
lui est de montrer la vocation
universelle de la france qui est autre
chose qu'un
indice atlantiste m'at-il confié ce
matin ses mots ils ont donc été repris
par marine le pen et par ses équipes
sans qu'ils en soient avertis mais il
trouve que c'est une très bonne chose et
une pâle marie coûteaux qui s'était
pourtant éloigné du front national ces
dernières années pourquoi tu y as
uniquement pour des raisons stratégiques
en fait car elle est opposée à la ligne
philippot qui l'a emporté 1 ces derniers
temps
cette ligne selon laquelle le front
national ni de droite ni de gauche pour
pas de marie coûteaux au contraire le
front national est de droite et doit
s'allier à d'autres forces de droite
et d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a été consternée par l'appel
de françois fillon à voter pour emmanuel
macron au second tour et en revanche il
a vu d'un très bon oeil le fait que
marine le pen fasse alliance avec
nicolas dupont aignan et qu'elle adoucit
sa ligne sur la sortie de l'euro marine
le pen qu'aujourd'hui il soutient en
résumé bien difficile de dire si
l'emprunt de marine le pen à françois
fillon est un plagiat ou un clin d'oeil
en tout cas il vient souligner un peu
plus la stratégie de la candidate dans
l'entre-deux tours qui après le
ralliement de nicolas dupont aignan
compte bien marquer des points auprès de
l'électorat de françois fillon
merci beaucoup tam emmanuel rivière
justement on voit bien l'ambition de
marine lepen dans cet entre-deux-tours
de ratisser large de s'adresser aux
électeurs de françois fillon c'est
peut-être qu'elle a voulu faire en
plagiant volontairement ce discours est
ce que on en voit les fruits justement
dans les intentions de vote de cette
stratégie
pour l'instant ses limites et ses allées
progresse par rapport à la précédente
enquête le sondage que nous avons rendu
public hier avec 41% des voix + 2 points
en dix jours alors qu'il reste cinq
jours c'est là où la cohésion devient
compliquée pour marine le pen parce que
n'étant pas en tête du premier tour et
il n'y en pas creuser cet écart qui en
général permettent au front national
d'espérer remporter un second tour alors
que le second tour lui sont assez
systématiquement défavorables
elle est obligée d'obtenir qu'une
majorité de certain électorat se reporte
sur elle et dans notre enquête c'est
pour l'instant le contraire de ce qui se
passe l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
comme l'électorat de françois fillon est
partagé entre trois options une partie
va vers l'abstention mais
à chaque fois une majorité relative se
porte sur emmanuel macron conformément
pour électorale hier de françois fillon
à ce que françois fillon lui-même a
déclaré et par bonne compréhension je
crois du comportement plus allusif de
jean-luc mélenchon et aussi parce que
lectorat mélenchon intrinsèquement
structurellement est un électorat qui
peut porter au vote pour marine le pen
même si même si marine le pen a
clairement fait des appels du pied aussi
aux insoumis et c'est là la difficulté
de cette équation d'ailleurs pour elle
c'est que elle refuse à choisir entre se
diriger leur ameuter les deux camps et
il en faudrait en outre un troisième qui
est celui des abstentionnistes du
premier tour tout intérêt à ce que
l'abstention soit très forte marine le
pen met pas du tout en fait on a
l'habitude de dire que le front national
intéresse qu à gré abstention soit forte
c'est vrai dans le cas au front national
à une belle avance et où il peut compter
sur les mauvais report des électeurs a
battu donc serait était vrai au second
tour des régionales quand le front
national avait plus de quinze points
d'avancé ou presque
selon la région mais là elle est
devancée donc et elle a besoin de
renfort de voix et ces renforts de voie
d'eau est ce qui peut venir
imaginons qu'une très forte abstention
dans un tiers des abstentionnistes qui
serait énorme pour une second tour de
présidentielle
il faudrait quand même 15 millions de
voix pour être élu au premier tour alors
vers la moitié donc il faut les chercher
sept millions et nuit malgré le
ralliement de nicolas dupont aignan
c'est ce qu'on peut déjà en mesurer les
et ça lui apporte
d'après notre sondage plutôt moins d'un
million imaginons qu'il est que c'est
1,1 million six verres sur marine le pen
il faudra encore en chercher quasiment 6
millions en a deux qui viennent sans
doute de françois fillon
peut-être un peu plus d'un million de
jean luc mélenchon et bâillements qu'à
peu près un million et demi de voix et
c'est pas et me benoît hamon qui va
aller lui donner puis les autres
candidats sont trop petits donc elle a
besoin pour gagner des vhu
abstentionnistes or il apparaît que une
partie des abstentionnistes pourrait
aller voter au second tour ce qui n'est
pas inhabituel d'ailleurs un des gens
qui considèrent qu' ils ne se déplacent
qu'au tour décisif qui était un peu dans
la confusion sur ce premier tour et qui
se disait bon on verra qui est au second
tour mais en l'occurrence là encore
quand on regarde le comportement dans
notre enquête des abstentionnistes ils
se partagent plus équitablement entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen mais
toujours avec un petit avantage emmanuel
macron justement emmanuel macron malgré
l'absence de front républicain on voit
que c'est difficile de mesurer les
effets qu'on a pu connaître en 2002 ils
restent favoris aujourd'hui dans les
sondages il reste un favori
baden parce que s'il perd deux points en
ce qui concerne la question des
intentions de vote
on se rend compte que son son image en
tant que président il perd huit points
il passe de 47 % à 39 % des français qui
pensent qu'il ferait un bon président de
la république alors ça reste toujours
plus que marine le pen qui est à 26 cela
étant on voit bien comment cette
campagne fin de campagne du premier tour
soirée du 1er tour et puis le début de
campagne qui a été plus chahuté lui a
été préjudiciable mais la question c'est
pas simplement est-ce que emmanuel
macron continue à être séduisant c est
ce qu il existe en france ou pas une
volonté de faire barrage au front
national et pour l'instant la logique on
voit dans cette enquête c'est qu'il ya
encore une hostilité assez forte plus de
la moitié des français qui disent jamais
je pourrais voter pour marine le pen qui
estimeraient que seraient ils
bénéficient de ce rejet a finalement ils
bénéficient de ce rejet est d'ailleurs
c'est clairement dans l'électorat qui
dit aujourd'hui se porter sur emmanuel
macron nous met en avant les deux tiers
qui nous disent ce n'est pas par
adhésion emmanuel macron mais par refus
de marine le pen c'est pour ça que d'un
point de vue stratégique il ne modifie
pas tellement son discours on l'a vu
contrairement à marine le pen qui
tentait bien d'adoucir sa position qui
inquiétait les français vis-à-vis
une sortie de l'union européenne
emmanuel macron lui c'est pas vraiment
de gestes que ce soit vers les
mélenchonistes comme les sionistes
oui d'autant que aujourd'hui il semble
qu'ils puissent bénéficier d'un report
si ce n'est majoritaire au sens de plus
de la moitié au moins par rapport à
marine le pen majoritaire dans ces deux
électorats et le risque pour lui en tant
dans les perches trop ostensiblement à
l'un des deux électorats serait perdre
le soutien de celui à qui se donne un
sentiment de de tourner le dos avec en
plus à risque de dégradation de sa
propre image on a beaucoup reproché
emmanuel macron d'être un peu trop
d'accord avec tout le monde
de n'avoir pas un projet très bien calé
ce pourrait être dangereux pour lui
donner le sentiment de consentir entre
dans cet entre-deux-tours à renoncer à
des parties de son programme ont
embrassé un programme qui n'est pas le
sien donc c'est vrai qu'il est en
position de favori alors salle expose
bien entendu ça mais marine le pen en
position de challenger ce qui est on se
crée les français aiment bien les
challengers par les temps qui courent
mais là il ya un écart qui s'est créée
dès le premier tour et avec
effectivement cette hostilité qui
demeure à l'égard du front national
notamment dans un électorat qui va être
nous sans doute décisif qui ait
l'électorat âgé qui a beaucoup voté pour
françois fillon est bien par rapport à
ce qu'on évoquait dans le premier sujet
c'est à dire cette idée d'une alliance
des droites sur la question de l'euro
mais pas uniquement sur la question de
l'euro l'électorat âgé est très hostile
et le demeure dans notre enquête au
front national
et ce sont les gros contingent parmi les
électeurs on a beaucoup parlé des
abstentionnistes il y aura aussi
beaucoup de votes blancs ça ça risque
d'être
une marque inédite dans un scrutin est
ce que ça aura pour conséquence le
risque d'un président qui pourrait être
mal élu selon vous alors la dernière
élection avec deux millions de votes
blancs au second tour c'est quasiment
une multiplication par trois du nombre
de votes blancs et nuls d'ailleurs parce
qu'à l'époque on les distingue à fait
que françois hollande a été élu avec
moins de la moitié des votants
plus de la moitié des exprimés
naturellement mais moins de la moitié
des votants là avec les cas s'il demeure
fort entre marine le pen et manuel da
cruz
je peux que manuel macron malgré une
forte augmentation du nombre de votes
blancs et nuls et 2 vote blanc sur
malgré tout élu avec une majorité des
votants mais effectivement dans notre
enquête s'il apparaît que 14 % des
interviewés l'ensemble des français
inscrits sur la liste électorale nous
disent considérer assez fortement de la
possibilité de voter blanc dimanche
cette semaine ça fragilise le processus
démocratique selon vous cette
comptabilisation du vote blanc on est
dans une élection de transition qui
était beaucoup par réceptacle du
mécontentement d'une certaine manière
c'est l'hymne des soupapes du
mécontentement à condition de savoir le
lire à condition de savoir le lire sera
tout le défi du prochain président élu
ou présidente
mais les pronostics sont plus favorables
à emmanuel macron ce sera effectivement
de ne pas donner le sentiment de
triomphe et trop facilement d'une
élection qui aura exprimé beaucoup plus
de mécontentement et de rejet il finit
que d'adhésion à un programme lorsque
l'on regarde les cotes les images des
candidats qui restent en présence en est
très en deçà des images et de l'appétit
que suscitaient les finalistes des
élections précédentes car merci beaucoup
emmanuel rivière pour votre analyse
michel grossiord va nous rejoindre dans
un instant sur ce plateau bonsoir michel
18h30 en direct sur public sénat édition
spéciale de l'épreuve de vérité spéciale
présidentielle avec deux ans le
tassement deux invités évidemment
représentant les deux candidats en lice
pour le duel de dimanche
pour emmanuel macron c'est jean paul
delevoye que nous recevrons c'est le
président de la commission d'investiture
un des candidats dans marche c'est lui
qui travaille sur la liste des 577
candidats et bien sûr on a hâte de
connaître sa réaction au vote des
insoumises les militants
de jean luc mélenchon qui se sont donc
prononcés aux deux tiers pour un vote
blanc ou l'abstention dimanche prochain
deuxième invités représentant marine le
pen est bien louis aliot le vice
président du front national par ailleurs
compagnon de la candidate à la ville et
on l'interrogera sur certains points du
programme qui changent alors
électoralisme évidemment se poser la
question après la disparition dans la
profession de foi et du discours de
marine le pen de la sortie de l'euro qui
est pourtant la base absolue de son
programme
merci beaucoup michel les promeneurs
étaient c'est donc à suivre en direct à
18h 30 vide avant cela retour sur les
meetings les deux candidats c'était à
l'occasion du 1er mai les conforts
sélectionné aujourd'hui par mounir souci
la réalité elle est simple elle est
claire emmanuel macron c'est françois
hollande qui veut rester et qui
s'accroche au pouvoir comme une bernique
emmanuel macron c'est françois hollande
qui continuera d'inspirer la politique
du pays
et bien ce candidat sortant nous allons
le sortir contraire à la liberté
le projet macron va à l'encontre de
l'égalité il ne peut y avoir d'égalité
pour les français dans le projet macron
puisque sa philosophie c'est en marche
ou crève
[Applaudissements]
et madame le pen ne l'a sifflé pas bâton
là c'est différent
[Applaudissements]
madame le pen a parfaitement résumé la
situation ce midi avec sa grossièreté
bien connue elle a dit
elle a dit c'est en mars ou crève elle a
raison en mars c'est nous
[Applaudissements]
hollande pas très loin d'ici c'était au
bourget disait en 2012 nous véritable
adversaire il n'a pas de nom pas de
visage pas de partis
il ne présentera jamais sa candidature
il ne sera jamais élu et pourtant ils
gouvernent cet adversaire c'est le monde
de la finance
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'adversaire du peuple
français c'est toujours le monde de la
finance
mais cette fois il a un nom il a un
visage
il a un parti il présente sa candidature
et tous rêvent de le voir et lui il
s'appelle emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
j'ai entendu ces derniers jours les
appels à changer le programme à dire
fait une concession rassemblés en
oubliant la réforme du travail
rassemblés en faisant ceci ou cela
non non c'est légitime certains l'ont
fait par le passé je ne le ferai pas
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
les françaises et les français se sont
exprimés et ont choisi le projet qui
porte ses réformes
je ne vais pas les trahir en les rognons
la deuxième chose c'est que je veux
demain pouvoir agir être efficace donc
ces réformes nous les avons conçu nous
les avons portés nous les ferons
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de m'avoir suivi tout de suite
l'épreuve de vérité spéciale élection
présidentielle invité ce soir louis
aliot vice président du front national
et jean paul delevoye président de la
commission des investitures en marche à
bonne soirée et à demain
[Musique]
et